how are you doing today sir
i'm very good steve i just saw on
twitter that you had put out a call to
um ask for questions for these
interviews and i saw that one of the
first replies to me was can you ask jack
whitehall if he's actually in it
so can we confirm to whoever it was that
asked that question
in a slightly shady way that i am
actually in this film and i haven't been
cut completely from the finished product
what's funny is you have a huge part in
this movie like
yeah i mean i have been cut from films
before so
i approach the screening with some
trepidation just because i know that
sometimes you can get a bad shakedown so
yeah i was very hard to see that
i am actually in it and i speak in this
one it's very funny you saw that because
i didn't tag you or anything
the guy that asked the question tagged
me oh god
no you hadn't been he did
funny oh so i want to jump backwards
because i believe you auditioned for
harry potter when you were a kid
yeah indeed indeed i was you know
taken to the audition by my parents they
were like please don't mess this up this
could be a huge career opportunity for
you as a child actor
i'd learn all my lines i felt like i
gave it my best shot
and in the end they decided that emma
watson was better for the part
what can i say
i'm serious though can you watch the
movies or is it one of those things that
it still hurts
do you know what i can watch those
movies because it was so young
and uh i don't feel like it was ever
really a realistic possibility that i
was gonna be in harry potter
uh yeah maybe subsequently i've got a
lot more bitter because now when i
audition for a part and i feel like i've
got close to it i can't watch the film
or enjoy it but
harry potter fortunately has not been
spoiled by my experience of
absolutely messing up my audition i
hadn't read the book that was the issue
they started asking me a lot of
questions about
harry potter and i hadn't completed the
book at that time
and that did not play particularly well
i think i started talking about goblins
and elves and stuff like that and got
slightly confused
it was not a great moment uh first of
all congratulations on jungle cruise
i don't see how anyone would watch this
movie and be like oh that's not good you
know this is this is a fun
fun movie um i love learning about the
behind the scenes of the making of a
film
um what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of
jungle cruise
i mean i think what might surprise them
is that
you know obviously there is some cgi in
the movie and there are some of those
action set pieces that have been built
in an editing suite but
for the first 20 minutes of that film
you know they actually built
this incredible port in
hawaii on a reservoir and all of that
uh like opening sequence you know we
were on a palpable set and we were
actually living it and
uh you know it's very rare to to have a
practical build like that and our
um you know designer and the whole
you know team behind the the kind of
like the visuals of this movie did such
an incredible job of like
literally bringing it to life and it was
one of the most amazing sets that i've
ever stepped onto
and i think people will really enjoy
that about the movie is that yeah it's
like you know really fun and and it's
got these like great moments and stuff
getting blown up and all of the things
that you want from a big summer
blockbuster but it
is also like a really like stunning like
visual treat
as well i completely agree i gotta stop
there
and i'm just gonna say uh congrats on
not getting cut out of this movie
and thank you for uh giving me your time
thank you i'm gonna tweet that guy back
and say that his question has been
answered by the way you totally should
that would be great